our ongoing series our more perfect
union aims to show that what unites us
as Americans is far greater than what
divides us an estimated ten thousand
blind Americans use Guide Dogs now there
is a growing effort to train these dogs
not just to be guides but also to be
athlete it's not about that Don Dahler
introduces us so the canines that are
helping blind runners keep afoot in the
race one stride at a time Tom Panik and
his guide dog Gus inch closer to their
goal the two have been training in local
parks like this for over three years
with the hopes of competing in an
officially sanctioned long-distance race
it's never been done before I've been
running my whole life I ran my
cross-country team in high school and I
ran as a young adult
Panik is the CEO of guiding eyes for the
blind a non-profit program that provides
Guide Dogs and services at no cost to
the blind community he lost his sight 25
years ago and with it his independence
when you lost your sight did you keep
running no when I lost my sight I was
too scared to run as he adjusted to his
blindness he began running with a human
guide but it wasn't the same Panik still
lacked the independence he once had
although many people run with running
clubs at the end of the day you're
running your own race and when you're
tied to another person it's no longer
your own race the independence isn't
quite there good job we first caught up
with Panik two years ago when he became
the CEO of guiding eyes for the blind
the idea of a running guide program was
first suggested by former Marine Richard
hunter who was blind and looking to get
back into running the two met at the
Boston Marathon in 2015 Richard shouted
out I'm really curious have you ever
trained a guide dog to run and I said I
don't know it hasn't been done a few
months and intense training sessions
later the running guide program was born
Panik and a small team helped train
clinger German Shepherd to aid Richard
with running baseline skill set for a
guide dog and running dog are the same
they're looking for overhead obstacles
and making sure that the person who's
blind like me remains safe as we're
mobile he formed a team of experts to
train a small group of dogs mostly
Labrador retrievers and German shepherds
to run long distances the dogs began
their training at 18 months old and it's
an exclusive club out of a hundred and
sixty-five graduate dogs only an
estimated 12 are considered race-ready
ving collie manages the guiding eyes
running program just 40 miles north of
New York City he works with a small team
of trainers every day on over 300
distinct skills that include endurance
agility and awareness how early do you
know whether a dog is gonna fit in with
that program so we do an initial
evaluation run and it's usually pretty
obvious at that point on that run
they're willing to go faster and they
enjoy the running but the team's
ultimate test would be a 5-mile race
through New York's Central Park just one
week before the New York City Marathon
it was panics and Gus's first
competitive race
before the race panic was overcome with
emotion wiping away his tears of
appreciation to the dog who gave him his
independence back once the race began
who's like a walk in the park complete
with their own cheering section every
two miles the duo made a precautionary
pit stop giving Gus a needed water break
and getting his pulse and paws checked
by a vet despite the unforgiving weather
and hordes of runners the team finished
strong crossing that finish line you
know it was a momentous occasion for me
the bond between runner and man's best
friend
groves we did it together I guess one
stride at a time good job buddy for CBS
this morning Don Dahler Yorktown Heights
New York Tom panic tells us it may be a
few years before we see one of his guide
dogs in a marathon it would most likely
resemble a relay with four to five dogs
running about five miles each but good
job buddy indeed another reason why dogs
I love them I know especially laboratory
yeah i defending this friend it's so
terrific running is a terrific sport and
yeah I'm glad that in blind will not
limit you and run yeah absolutely right